et nous sommes en direct avec leila
chaibi députée européenne la france
insoumise bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
à leur première question en quoi
consisterait un état d'urgence social
européen
alors les conséquences sociales
économiques de la crise sanitaire de la
pandémie
elles sont dramatiques je crois que tous
les états membres de l'union européenne
le constate et elles sont pas près de
s'arrêter
c'est à dire que même si demain tout le
monde est là qu signer les conséquences
à voir se faire endurer sur le long
terme on a passé en france la barre des
10 millions de pauvres
il n'ya qu'à écouter ce que nous disent
les associations qui délivrent des
paniers repas aux gens pour bien voilà
entendre que les personnes qui font la
queue pour les demandes d'aidé
alimentaire
c'est pas le public qu'elle avait
l'habitude de voir mais ça va être des
personnes qui auparavant n'auraient
jamais imaginé se retrouver là des
personnes qui sont victimes des plans de
licenciement il faut savoir que depuis
moins d'octobre
il ya eu en france 30 plan de
licenciement par semaine votre reportage
l'indiqué il ya une manifestation pour
dénoncer ces plans de licenciements cet
après midi sept cent mille personnes
dorment dans la rue en europe
donc je disais les demandes de paniers
alimentaires explose tout pas rester
uniquement sur la france
un dernier chiffre puis après l'idée
c'est pas de noyer de chiffres mais à
barcelone
a barcelone on est passé de 25 mille
panier alimentaire donner aux gens dans
le besoin à 500 milles vous imaginez une
augmentation par par jean donc face à
cette situation
on a demandé avec la délégation transmis
cette semaine au parlement européen à ce
que l'union européenne déclare l'état
d'urgence sociale qu'est ce que ça
signifie
ça signifie que désormais si on veut pas
complètement tomber dans le précipice
et puis que la crise s aggrave encore la
priorité dans l'union européenne
ça doit plus être de respecter la
concurrence de faire valoir le marché
la rigueur budgétaire et tous ses dogmes
qui dirige qui irrigue les politiques
européennes depuis des années des années
désormais on doit changer de logiciel
parce que la priorité ça doit être de
faire face aux conséquences sociales de
la pandémie est donc désormais c'est lui
jean social c'est la notion d'urgence
sociale qui doit être un objectif qui
doit irriguer de façon transversale
toutes les politiques de l'union
européenne alors je peux vous donner
quelques exemples comme ça concrètement
donc on a vu que les principes dont on
pensait qu'ils étaient figés dans le
marbre
par exemple vous savez il ya un principe
quand vous êtes un état membre de
l'union européenne
c'est que vous devez pas dépasser 3% du
pib en déficit dans vos dépenses
mais ça c'est un problème parce que
c'est ce qui fait que et ben les
dépenses de santé par exemple les
dépenses dans l'hôpital public dont on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui qu'on a tellement
besoin
et ben 63 fois l'union européenne en dix
ans a dit aux états membres sous forme
de recommandations entre guillemets mais
en mettant bien la pression le radis 63
fois vous devez arrêter de dépenser en
matière de santé et donc c'est ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui les hôpitaux sont
saturés
donc on a vu à quel point à un moment
donné dans durant la crise on a dit bon
allez stop maintenant ces critères le 3
% on arrête donc ils sont patents figé
dans le marbre
et donc maintenant nous on demande à ce
que ce soit de manière pérenne qu'on les
enlève parce qu'il faut investir dans
les services publics pour vous donner
des mesures très concrètes en réponse à
l'urgence qu'on pourrait prendre dès
demain dès demain il ya une demande qui
est aussi celle des associations de
mal-logés d'avoir une trêve hivernale
des expulsions
c'est à dire que quand on est locataire
quand on a des difficultés à payer son
loyer parce que bon on a perdu son
emploi parce qu'il faut choisir entre
payer le loyer ou manger et bien en
période d'hiver hivernale il ne peut pas
y avoir d'expulsion on peut pas mettre
les gens à la rue sans leur proposer un
relogement et donc on demande à ce que
tous les états membres de l'union
européenne s'engage là dessus est-ce que
vous avez noué des alliances avec
d'autres forces politiques de pays
européens pour réclamer cet état
d'urgence déjà donc tout l'ensemble du
groupe de la gauche au parlement
européen le groupe auquel j'appartiens
donc il faut savoir que dans un gauche
au parlement européen il ya des
espagnols il ya des grecs qui a des
danois il ya des allemands et on fait
tous ce constat et c'est une proposition
qui émerge ce groupe là donc il n'est
pas qui a été donc initié par la france
soumise donc des français et mais quand
on a discuté avec nos collègues nous ont
dit bah oui mais en fait enfin voila
c'est quelque chose qu'on partage
largement
et donc c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas évidemment franco français moi je
suis membre de la commission emploi et
affaires sociales
alors c'est vrai que dans cette
commission il ya un peu les personnes
qui ont la fibre sociale mais même quand
on a des députés de droite un peu ceux
qui ont la fibre sociale
on voit que cette proposition cette
demande à les partager
vous savez en décembre 2019 donc il ya à
peine plus d'un an
le parlement européen a déclaré l'état
d'urgence environnemental et écologique
ça a été possible donc c'était avant le
coc vide ça a été possible sur la
question environnementale et écologique
parce que tout le monde admettez qu'on
allait dans le mur d'un point de vue du
réchauffement climatique je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la question des
conséquences sociales de la crise
sanitaire elle fait consensus et on est
en capacité de la portée d'abord au
parlement européen et puis ensuite s'en
servir dans le rapport de force
vis-à-vis de la commission européenne
pour forcer la commission européenne à
mettre en place un revenu minimum qu'ils
soient axés accessible également aux
jeunes pour arrêter avec ces règles
stupides de l'austérité de la rigueur
qui empêche les états d'apporter des
aides à des secteurs de l'économie sous
préfecture qui ferait concurrence au
marché privé
donc je crois évidemment je suis
enthousiaste on a présenté cette
proposition lors de cette plénière
cette semaine on va on va évidemment
continuer le travail l'objectif étant
bien que le parlement déclare l'état
d'urgence sociale et ensuite l'union
européenne et que ce soit traduit en
actes merci beaucoup en tout cas les la
gemmi d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes députée
européenne la france insolite